also schon Sport hatte wirklich viel
lernen dürfen sehr viel harte
Erfahrungen da machen müssen aber auf
die würde im Nachhinein eine verzichten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
des österreichischen Bundesheers heute
zu Gast Olympia 4 Weltmeister bei den
U23 Herren und
hoffmeisterschaft im Wildwasser Kajak
cobraal Felix Oschatz herzlich
willkommen hallo ich habe jetzt einige
Folgen von dir schon aufgezählt der
größte natürlich der Olympia vierte
eingebettet in Nachwuchs Medaillen und
auch schon allgemeine Medaillen in Tokio
dann vierten Platz gemacht im Wildwasser
Kajak haarscharf an der Medaille vorbei
wie schaust du jetzt schon ein bisschen
zeitlichen Abstand auf dieses Resultat
zurück für mich waren für die Zeit in
Tokio das war wirklich die größte Zeit
meiner sportlichen Laufbahn bis jetzt
ist es olympische Spieler so ähm das
kann man so oft man will beschreiben
versuchen aber das wird niemanden
verstehen was das ist wenn man jetzt
selbst dort war das Ergebnis ist für
mich noch nach wie vor super sportlicher
Leistung am quasi hautnah verfolgt hat
der Wasser mit was für ein riesigen
Fehler mir diese Leistung gelungen ist
deswegen kann ja glaube umso stolzer
sein dass sie ja mit so einem Fehler
vierter sein haben dürfen und das war
einfach für mich ja ganz besonderer Tag
du nimmst es sehr sportlich siehst es
auch sehr sportlich ich habe selber
schon mal die Erfahrung gemacht dass ich
um 2600 das ist im Schwimmen ganz ganz
wenig die Paralympics Medaillen London
verpasst habe mir eigentlich nichts
vorwerfen konnte das Rennen perfekt war
und man hat er dann trotzdem manchmal
damit man sich denken was wäre denn
gewesen hattest du auch solche Momente
wenn der Fehler nicht passiert ja egal
das sind vielleicht der kleine
Unterschied dass sie halt doch wirklich
ein gravierenden Fehler gemacht habe wo
er halt gewusst habe wenn man vergleicht
mit dem semi Finale wie im Semi Finale
denselben Streckenabschnitt gefahren bin
dass er gewusst habe okay es ist an mir
gelegen ich habe aber mein bestes geben
dass Fehler passieren jeder ist nur
Mensch und wenn man als Fehler
behafteter Mensch trotzdem für das sein
darf nachher habe nie mit mir gehadert
natürlich man man träumt genauso wie man
davor voneinander träumt als Ziel träumt
man danach nicht dieser Medaille nach
sondern vielleicht von einer zukünftigen
würde ich sagen ja man hat eine
Bestätigung dass eine zukünftig auf
jeden Fall im Rahmen des Möglichen ist
wenn man es so einen vierten Platz
schafft definitiv wenn man so einen
vierten Platz schafft dann war es mal
okay wenn es so weitermacht wenn ihr
einfach weiter ja drauf schaut dass sie
meine Ziele verfolgt da müssen in
Zukunft sicher abplatz besser drinnen
das jetzt gesagt der Traum war natürlich
davor auch schon da war das für dich so
konkret zu greifbar dass du in Tokio da
wirklich das Potenzial hast du schon in
Tokio am Podium zu verstehen ja auf
jeden Fall also ich bin ja er war im
Zeit die 15 bin weil wirklich bei jedem
EM-Finale mit dabei ich habe im Jahr
davor also im Olympia ja weil bei der EM
5er und beim letzten mal gehabt vor die
Spieler weil zweiter also es war für
mich ganz klar dass sie also das Thema
Finale Mercedes ob denn und wenn dann
die zehn besten der Welt Olympischen
Spiele gegeneinander antreten dann muss
man es realistisch sein und sagen es
kann alles passieren also da war für
mich auf jeden Fall das Ziel dass sie im
Finale einfach mein Bestes gibt und da
wollt ihr mit am vierten Platz genauso
zufrieden sein wir haben auch mehr am
achten oder zweiten und ich glaube das
habe ich ganz gut nachher für mich
umgesetzt also das auch bewusst
vorgenommen weil es wirkt so als hättest
du dir schon viele Gedanken vor allem im
mentalen Bereiche in die Richtung
gemacht oder ist das einfach deine
Typologie so ein bisschen von beiden ich
glaube war für mich weil es war für mich
davor klar dass er für die Olympischen
Spiele sind das größte was es gibt und
das ist einfacher einmaliger Erfahrung
die nicht viele Menschen auf der Welt
machen dürfen ich habe natürlich immer
nachgedacht wie jetzt für mich laufen
und die wollte dann nicht wenn er es
auch der Hand vor aber eben mein bestes
geben habe und einfach so wie du sagst
nein geht nicht mehr her dass ein
hundert Entscheidungen und wenn es
nachher auch der Platz ist immer Bestes
geben habe und dann halt sieben sieben
Sport trainieren gleich viel wie ihr und
die haben es genauso verdient besser
sein als jeder wollte nicht enttäuschten
mir dann bitteren Gefühl von dieser
einmaligen Erfahrung haben fahren
deswegen habe ich mir das schon so
gerichtet in meinem Kopf dass er sagt
drinne ist das ist meine Niveau und
unter dieser top dann dort brauchen
niemand sich jemand Treiben nicht unsere
ersten Preis das klingt auf jeden Fall
schon sehr reif von dir damit bist du
auf jeden Fall vorbereitet für
zukünftige Erfolge aber auch um
Rückschläge zu meistern jetzt bleiben
wir kurz bei deiner Sportart selbst wenn
man so ein Olympia Finale mal geschaut
hat weiß man ja wie schnell es im
Wildwasser hergeht und wie schnell
solche Fehler auch passieren wo man gar
nicht sagen kann warum konzentriert oder
flüssigkeitsfehler sondern das war halt
einfach so da war plötzlich eine
Strömung da jemand so nicht dann Radar
hatte erklär mal was man so braucht in
so einem Finale und da wirklich auf den
Punkt genau die Leistung zu bringen ja
so würdest es ist Sparta von dynamischen
Element im Wasser hat was nicht die
ganze zeitgleich ist man schaut sich die
Strecke von außen endlich einmal an man
trainiert sehr viel darauf also man
versucht dieser Strömungen zu kennen und
zu wissen da kann man das Auftreten oder
so aber in diesem Moment das ist einfach
so viel auf was man achten muss auf dass
man sich dann aber nicht zu sehr
fokussieren sollte man hat ja trotzdem
das alles haben sich intuitiv
antrainiert und eben in Olympia Finale
aber jetzt im nachher einfach nur darum
auf seine Stärken zu vertrauen und
einfach dem Sportler ich quasi freien
Lauf zu lassen dass da einfach sagst
okay koordinativ kann er das alles was
sie machen muss und ja jetzt ist einfach
Gott time und das ist Vollgas was
würdest du sagen sind denn diese Stärken
auf die du dich so verlassen kannst wenn
es darauf ankommt bei dir war der
jüngste Stadt am Finale und ich habe
schon gewusst dass sie definitiv an oder
fittesten Start aber bin und das hilft
auf jeden Fall nicht so großen
Drucksituationen findet ihr auf jeden
Fall dass wenn ähm kleine Fehler
passieren wenn man die dann doch mit
einer bissel zusätzlich noch korrigieren
kann dass man da nicht glauben Konzept
ist oder leider läuft da hin ist das war
für mich auf jeden Fall der große
Absicherung der wo ihr Glaube Mangel der
erfahren im Vergleich zu anderen wett
machen hat keinen und die glaube ich bin
ja sehr kontrolliert erfahren
spektakulärsten fast jeder bei mir
geht's eigentlich eher darum durchgehend
dann Grund hohen Speed zu erhalten und
möglichst rund zu fahren und dadurch
glaube ich kann mal konstanta von hohen
Niveau fahren und seine persönliche
Leistung konstante abrufen als wenn man
ja Topper Flop quasi das ganze anliegt
wie schaut euer Bewerb konkret aus für
alle die vielleicht vom Wildwasserkajak
nur alle vier Jahre mal etwas
mitbekommen was das kann man sich denn
darunter vorstellen also
Wildwasserstrecke zwischen 250 und 500 m
lang das Rennen was von Start bis hier
stattfindet dauert dann zwischen 80 und
100 Sekunden ungefähr für die charakern
auf dieser Strecke sind 22 bis 26 Tore
verteilt die entweder flussabwärts
passiert werden müssen oder sechs bis
acht von dieser Tore müssen eben auch
Strom aufwärts passiert wenn dieser
Strom aufwärts was zu passieren und
hängen dann meistens natürlich eben in
Kehrwassern wo das Wasser die Strömung
quasi durch davor stehende Steine oder
Objekte blockiert wird und genau und
dann geht es ihm darum das Wasser zu
lesen die schnellsten möglich sein
Berliner zu finden das ist im Endeffekt
Schiefbahn nur von flüssigen Schnee
liegt hier wenn das sondern dann länger
ist wenn es kürzer ist was was liegt dir
wenn es eben nicht immer überall die
gleiche länger die gleiche Dauer das
Rennens ist was liegt gar nicht sagen
dass bei mir Distanz den Unterschied
macht sondern für mich ist es eher gut
wenn der Kurs so gesteckt ist oder
ausgehangen ist dass das er bisher ein
Rhythmus vorgibt dann bislang Wechsel
das einzelne Passage sind ist recht
knackig sind hart sind und dann halt da
kurzer Abschnitt wo er zwischen Sprint
ist oder etwas so kann ich einfach
generell mein ganzen Lauf besser
rhythmisieren und beißen und das
unterstützt glaube ich mir meine Stärke
Männer so ist wenn du sagst wenn der
Kurs gesteckt ist verstehst auf der
gleichen Strecke im nächsten Jahr der
Kurs anders sein kann stimmt genau es
ist gemeinsam perfekt gibt's unendlich
Möglichkeiten um da dann kurz zu hängen
was auf weil eben ja es jeder
abwärtskombination kann man bisschen
schwerer bisschen leichter machen
Seitenvergleich dann hängt einmal im
nächsten Jahr in dem
Kawasaki war und ja wir sind deswegen
extrem viel unterwegs wenn man auf
dieser Strecken einfach sehr sehr viele
Möglichkeiten durchprobieren muss und
trotzdem kommt sehr sehr selten vor dass
man an Kurs der im Rennen ist schon mal
Ernährungsweise im Training trainiert
hat wer steckt sowas wer sucht sich das
Aus für Wettkämpfe die Teamleiter
teilnehmenden Nationen bei solchen
Rennen aber internationalen Rennen die
haben da vor dem die das mit denen wo
quasi jemand ausgelöst wird oder er hat
den Kurse hängen darf mit Unterstützung
der gastgewerten Nation und
bei Weltmeisterschaften und Olympischen
Spielen ähm ist es so dass
der internationale Verband engagiert
jemanden der keinen Verband zugehörig
sein darf und quasi die ja den Kurs
Hengst und der nachher im Endeffekt die
wichtigen Entscheidungen trifft wo
welche Doris sind damit das möglichst
verabläuft damit man nicht einen Kurs
hängt der dir zum Beispiel super liegen
würde damit du dann den Vorteil dass nur
alle vier Jahre Olympische Spiele sind
dann soll's nicht quasi ja über so eine
Sache entschieden werden das heißt der
schreibt man natürlich das ist auch
halbwegse fair ist das soweit ist auch
möglich ist jetzt hat ihr eine
Trainingsstrecke eine jetzt mittlerweile
nicht mehr also relativ neu sage ich
jetzt mal in Wien wie wichtig war dass
wir dann wieder dass er kein Sport dass
man daheim gut und
intensiv trainieren kann ja also es ist
schon sehr wichtiges Trainingsniveau hat
man da einfach extrem steigern können
weil man hat es sich erstens
Reiseaufwand zu andere Destinationen
können und gleichzeitig zu Hause noch
höher qualitativ trainieren können und
dadurch ja ist einfach ist einfach alles
besser über eine Reanimation besser
geworden und man hat das Trainings dem
Trainingsplan noch besser umsetzen
können und egal was extrem wichtig dass
man so Strecker in seinem Land hat wo
man einfach immer wieder zurückkehren
kann und auch wenn man zu Hause ist
einfacher fürstenniveau weiter arbeiten
kann wie stark können Sie da variieren
mit
Schwierigkeitsgraden mit den Dingen die
du jetzt erklärt hast die wichtig sind
bei euch genau da kann man natürlich ja
die Tore noch Belieben verziehen und
verhängen man kann sich vorstellen dass
er quasi sehr künstlicher Fluss der
nachgestellt ist also betonschneider und
durch die dann das Wasser runter rennt
und in dieser bestimmer
am leben müssen ist es so wie Lego man
kann da diese Einbauten umstecken und
dadurch kann man noch Haare den Kanal
ändern das passiert jetzt nicht sehr oft
weil es halt wirklich schwierig ist aber
gut nutzbare Strecke herzustellen aber
im Endeffekt ist es schon eine
nachhaltiges Konzept um ein Zukunft neu
Herausforderungen und dann alle paar
Jahre wieder mal einbauen zu können
das wäre dann das spezifische Training
so würde ich verstehen dass du wirklich
auf dem bewegten Element trainierst aber
kannst du deinen Sport auch anders
simulieren kannst du am Land trocken
genau das das Kajak trainieren genau
natürlich wird bei uns ist aber
natürlich da Kraftakt sehr entscheidend
da gibt's sehr viele verschiedene
Philosophien von National
unterschiedlich wo man halt wirklich
mehr funktionaler Fitness setzen und
Herr auf ganz klassisches Krafttraining
das ja findet bei mir im dreimal die
Woche statt und das ist einfach
wichtiger Faktor damit man auch haben im
positiven Fitness hat und es gibt da
buddelergometer was im Jahr sehr ähnlich
zu seinem Bruder Ergometer oder Rat
Ergometer ist wo es aber eben so wie bei
dieser pennen und dann Geräte einfach
das Gefühl anderers wie ist wie im Boden
es ist ein extrem schlechter Tage im
Winter gute Ausweichmöglichkeit aber ja
man kann es daneben zum Beispiel gar
nichts schauen wir am Rat Ergometer oder
so das heißt das wird dann wirklich ja
extrem langweilig und monoton deswegen
bevorzugt man manchmal bei Wien Stille
an Minusgrade und geht aus Wasser
paddeln da ist dass man sich aufs
baliago setzt mittlerweile wenn wir ein
bisschen damit anfreundet weil es
einfacher recht guter Trainingssteuerung
ist mit der Watt die man genau angezeigt
kriegt aber es ist mehr als Option wird
es nie bleiben das wollte ich vorher da
auch dahin kommen ich habe ja schon
Bilder gesehen von euch wo wir da
wirklich fast schon im Schnee und so und
am Eis vorbei japanels einfach nur also
so kalt hat es gewirkt einfach nur damit
ihr Wasser seid wie wie geht man mit
alter mitunter seinem kalt ist und man
trotzdem immer Wasser sein muss
kälteste Trainingslager was man gehabt
haben warme zweiter bis 8 januar oder so
in Prag und der hat halt wirklich anhand
der minus 15 Grad hat und den Moldau war
gefahren und nur die kalkstrecke wo das
Wasser halt wild genug war und das Eis
aufzubrechen war halt ohne Eis
da ist in der Früh muss man sich schon
extra motivieren dass man dass man sich
raus ist nasse wagt und ja man sieht sie
halt einfach es ist ja wir haben
spezielle Kleidung und am Körper wenn
man sich dann mal wirklich Aufgaben
diesen bewegt und nicht zu lange stehen
bleibt dazwischen ist es am Körper
eigentlich wirklich okay weil der sich
so erhitzt aber eben in die Füße in die
in die Beine in die Finger und im
Gesicht wird das halt einfach wirklich
extrem kalt egal ob man sich mit
Vaseline einschmiert Handschuhe anzieht
oder nur bremssatteln also diese
Körperstellen die leiden dann schon also
das ist richtig hart war aber natürlich
nicht in die Wintermonate Wochen lang
nicht aufs Wasser gehen weil es kalt ist
also das ist wahrscheinlich ein Faktor
der dann auch entscheidet sein kann oder
definitiv man kann im Solar sagt einfach
wochenlange das Wasser gehen und wenn
man dann irgendwann mal sagen Anfang -2
Grad nach hätte Wille nicht oder hätte
hätte
was anderes stattdessen dann ist es
irgendwie schwer finde die Grenze zu
ziehen deswegen ist er sage okay ich
gehe immer aufs Wasser außer es geht
jetzt wirklich gar nicht weil ja halt
voller Wind da noch ist und dann kannst
du nichts halt baden oder irgendwas aber
an anderen für sich soll es eigentlich
schon immer im Kopf alles Settings sein
hat er geballen das heißt man muss das
schon wirklich wollen du willst es
natürlich jetzt ist der Unterschied zu
anderen Kanu Sportarten dass dir nicht
unbedingt nass werden wenn sie es nicht
wollen also sie können sich über Wasser
halten das ist bei euch unmöglich
eigentlich oder ja auf jeden Fall also
wenn du ein Bild was da drin ist dann
hast das ist einfach so da kannst du
noch so vorsichtig versuchen zu fahren
das ja erstens mal eine kurze verlangen
wenn es einfach dass mein gewisser
wählen oder Weizen ebenso rein fährt
dass man wirklich komplett nass ist aber
abgesehen davon
es passieren im Training manchmal Fehler
und manchmal lernt man sie irgendwo hin
zu weit oder so und dann ist da halbe
Kopf im Wasser oder so und dann ja muss
mal kurz den hirnfrost aussetzen und
dann geht's weiter es ist das spannende
weil wir in dem Sinne zwei Elemente hast
das bewegte Wasser aber auch das Boot
das ist natürlich ein Element wie kann
man sich von kajakobot vorstellen was
der Unterschied zu anderen
Kategorien für mich geübte leute das ist
einmal sehr eng weil da Leute die vielen
mal so Hobby plastikbote herumfahren
wenn die sich dann probieren in einer
slalombo zu setzen das ist einfach viel
flacher und viel länger ja es ist
komplett das gewohnt es hat da gewisses
Mindestgewicht 9 Kilo oder Mindestlänge
- breiter als das recht stark nominiert
nur die Form die kann eben da Hersteller
variieren und anpassen und das Volumen
passt man halt selbst dann also gibt mal
vor als Athlet umsonst seine Körpermasse
anzupassen wenn man eben zu kleines Boot
hat dreht man liegt sie aber extrem tief
im Wasser und es langsam beim
Vorwärtsfahren und das zu groß ist dann
ist es eben genau umgekehrt und das muss
jeder vermitteln Ding finden jeder hat
sein Sitz hat bisher anders drinnen im
Boden ich schneide mal sitzt zum
Beispiel hinten ein bisschen anders mit
dem mit dem Rücken weniger Probleme hat
beim Zurücklehnen es ist so wie in jeder
Sportart wo Material inkludiert ist es
ist natürlich nie aufhören wird das
heißt im Endeffekt bist du fast schon
materialtechniker auch noch wenn du ein
guter Wildwasser krankfahrer sein
möchtest oder ja ein gewisser Art schon
vor allem in unserer Sportart weil davon
nicht so viel Geld drinnen ist da hat
nicht jeder hat jetzt zwar Service
Männer mit sondern da hast du es
Österreich haben wir halt gar niemanden
mit der im für das zuständiges und wenn
irgendwas ist dann kümmert man sich
selbst um was ich überlegen wie das am
besten ist so und sammelst über die
Jahre Erfahrung wie man am besten mit
seinem Material umgeht ja kann man mit
Material dann auch wirklich den
Unterschied machen also nehmen du bist
der weltbeste Erfahrung oder vergreifst
dich im Olympia Finale beim Brot oder
oder schneidet den Sitz zu hoch an und
dann genau in die Richtung ich würde
sagen man kann nicht mit Material
gewinnen aber man kann ja mit dem
Material definitiv in die andere
Richtung in den Unterschied machen auf
jeden Fall also wenn du da nicht genau
der Boot hast oder einfach irgendwas ja
irgendwas falsch passiert oder die
saisona falsches Wagen ist eingehst
indem du an rossmodell fährst und das
sagt er gar nicht dazu ähm dann kannst
du auf jeden Fall damit ein ganzes
Können und der ganze Arbeit also nicht
da machen ja das heißt die Erfahrung die
Routine ist in dem Sinne auf jeden Fall
wertvoll und es nicht so dass das einen
die jungen schneller man um die Ohren
fahren weil eben genau diese Komponente
fehlt oder ja bei uns ist seit der guter
Mix in der Sportart findet ihr also um
weil halt das sehr großer körperlicher
Anteil da ist muss man natürlich
Vergleich zum
Akrobatik geschrieben schwimmen oder zum
Skispringen oder so weil man extrem
junge Leute manchmal wirklich weit vorne
mit dabei sind das funktioniert halt bei
uns sehr schwer weil halt einfach es
gibt Ausnahmen aber das dann halt
wirklich auseinander einfach die
körperliche Komponente aus so
entscheidend ist und man halt einfach
wirklich mit 25 einfach körperlich am
biologisch am besten leistungsfähig ist
aber eben man kann es ihm wirklich sehr
lange nachher noch rauszögern bisschen
die in die Mitte von von also 35 oder so
weil man halt einfach die Erfahrung
sammelt und die Strecken nachher schon
so gut kennt sondern einfach sich selbst
und das materialer
es klingt ja ein Spatz für mich wenn ich
da jetzt die 35 zugehe du hast das
Training schon angesprochen wie viel
Stunden kann man ungefähr rechnen am
Wasser zu sein dann effektiv also nicht
nur mit Krafttraining sondern wie viel
wie lange ist man so am Wasser an einem
durchschnittlichen Trainingstag okay
dann durchschnittlichen Trainingstag das
sind dann
ja es hängt natürlich davon ab was an
diesem Tag geplant ist aber ich würde
sagen es inzwischen zwei einhalb und
drei Stunden ja das ist doch längere
Strecken die man dann ja auf jeden Fall
vor allem wir sind ja schnell kräftiger
Sportart und da kannst Du nachher nicht
einfach zwei drei Stunden Einheiten
machen wo du halt ja das funktioniert
das ist halt dann halt nichts mehr mit
der Ente in der Sportart am Ende zu tun
und deswegen sind unsere Einheiten
meistens am Wildwasser eben zwischen ein
und anderthalb Stunden und immer
Flachwasser maximal zwei Stunden aber
das kommt das ja selten vor weil
irgendwann man arbeitet dann von mir
kleinere Muskelgruppen als beim
Radfahren oder so und irgendwann ist es
dann am Anfang immer so gut möglich dass
man so sobaldelt beim Skifahren sieht
man oftmals die die fahren wie sie im
staatshaus Stehen und und die die Kurven
durchgehen und und wie sie
den den Schwung ansetzen müssen geht das
dass ihr euch eine Strecke mental merkt
nach dem Einfahren nach dem Training
dass ihr wisst da muss ich das machen
und das machen also merkt man sich das
wirklich kann man das absprechen auf
jeden Fall vor allem wir dürfen immer
auf der Strecke dem Rennen hängt dürfen
wir kein einziges Mal runterfahren und
trainieren dann können wir immer nur vom
Ufer aus anschauen und umso wichtiger
ist es dass man halt umso öfter
visualisiert wie man noch hat
tatsächlich durch die Strecke Fahrt weil
dann ist es halt am Start wirklich so
als ob man zumindest schon mal durch die
Strecke durchgefahren ist klar was man
nie ganz genau was man erwarten wird
aber wenn man halt viel auf der Strecke
trainiert hat und dann sich den Kurs gut
anschaut dann kann man diese zwei
Informationen wenn man das wirklich
trainiert dann übt sehr gut kombinieren
und da passiert dann ganz das Gleiche
eben das mal bis ich wirklich vorstellen
wie es ist wenn man in diesem Tor ist
auf was man achten muss man vielleicht
durchtauchen muss wo man sich ein
bisschen mehr Zeit lassen muss und das
ist auf jeden Fall ganz ganz
entscheidend ja du musst in dem Moment
ganz ganz viele Dinge überblicken du
musst dir das Wasser beobachten wie
komme ich Strömungen du musst auf dein
Part achten du darfst dir die Tore nicht
berühren wieder mit Paddeln noch mit
deinem Körper als auf den Körper muss
auch noch achten ist das so dass wenn
man da ins Ziel kommt wirklich komplett
hin ist also wohl körperlich als auch
vom Kopf ja ich glaube man merkt im Kopf
wenn wirklich das am absoluter overload
ist weil blöder Vergleich aber so beim
Skifahren da ist halt wirklich die Linie
und eben die Körperhaltungen wie man zum
Tor dazu fährt aber wenn ihr das da halt
nachher richtig anfordern dann in
Endeffekt war es richtig und bei uns
können wir sagen nachdem das dazu dass
sie da eben möglichst eng fahren muss
aber gar nicht erst berühren darf oder
Gefahr entsteht weil wenn er dann mal
ausweichen muss dann ist es natürlich ja
gravierender Fehler wenn auf man sich
auf einmal die falsche Richtung bewegen
anfängt das ist etwas wenn man eben man
muss auch so viel achten aber wenn man
auf einzelne Sachen so genau zu achten
Anfang dann kommt man irgendwann einmal
hinten nach und alles zerfallt und
deswegen im Ziel natürlich extrem
anstrengend aber mehr kann immer das im
Kopf noch reicht einmal die nächsten
fünf bis zehn Minuten ja braucht man es
mir nichts spezifisches
wenn du so wie heuer dann auch schon
angefangen hast die Medaillen zusammen
Weltmeisterschaft bei der U23
Weltmeisterschaft auch deine Medaillen
bei der Europameisterschaft Medaillen
die du gemacht hast das heißt das
Medaille sammeln geht jetzt
offensichtlich richtig los kannst du dir
auch konkrete Anzahl an Medaillen
vorgenommen kann man sagen ich möchte
zehn mal bei der Europameisterschaft von
Stocker stehen fünfmal wer der
Weltmeisterschaft oder nimmt man es mit
so wie es kommt und am besten der Model
Maria also für mich war es ich habe
jetzt keine spezifisches Ziel aber für
mich war heute nachdem letztes Jahr zwei
Weltcup Medaille gemacht habe bin
Spieler so knapp dran war war für mich
schon klar als sie will in Zukunft
weiterhin machen und das war mein
Motivation nachher wo genau es ist das
glaube ich schwierig sich so vor einmal
im Endeffekt will man jedes Rennen gut
fahren dass es mit dem Zyklus jetzt
nicht jedes Rennen perfekt zusammenpasst
und manchmal mal besser vorbereitet ist
und manchmal noch ein Trainingsaufbau
für das nächste große Ereignis das muss
man so nehmen wie es kommt aber man kann
da ist ist es unmöglich haben wir leider
zu machen ja im Jahr ist noch am Ende
sein werden umso besser natürlich und
natürlich das große Ziel die Olympia
Medaille deine Freundin Daniela Ulbing
hat sich diesen Traum ja schon erfüllt
nämlich in Peking wenn Olympischen
Spielen bei der Winterspielen
Silbermedaille im Snowboard gewonnen wie
hast du das erlebt ich war gerade auf
Trainingslager in
aller in das ist in der Nähe von Dubai
das ist immer
wildwasseranlage und dann hat man bei
uns Winter ist es dort zwar auch Winter
aber es hat im Jahr zwischen 20 und 30
Grad perfekt der Trainingsbedingungen
für sommersportart und durch die
Zeitverschiebung weil sie eben im Peking
war und ihr war quasi bisschen in die
Richtung nachgeflogen bin von der
Zeitzone aber immer perfekt fahren
zwischen den Trainings habe Olympia
schauen können und natürlich ich immer
Ihre Bewerbung der wir ja richtig die
Daumen gedruckt hat und war dann ja
wirklich sehr sehr glücklich und
erleichtert wie sie noch haben vom
Halbfinale wo man nachher eben ja ins
Finale weitergegangen Kommunismus und
nachher eben ja sich zwischen Gold und
Silber nur noch die Frage gestellt hat
und ja das war echt sehr schöner Moment
von mir wo man noch halbjährigkeit
telefoniert haben und es war echt schön
dass mit mitverfolgen zu können ist das
noch mal eine zusätzliche Motivation für
dich ihr werdet sagen dass ich meine
Motivation dadurch geändert hat aber es
ist einfach wenn man diese Emotionen
einmal so miterleben darf zwar nur als
Außenstehender aber doch so naja dann
würde ich sagen ist das Bestätigung in
der Motivation auf jeden Fall ich bin
jetzt sehr sicher dass wir mit dir junge
Junge werden was wolltest du denn als
Kind
reichen schaffen als Kind habe nie so
speziell dieser sportvorstellungen oder
irgend sowas gehabt eigentlich immer ja
und immer gemacht habe Spaß gehabt aber
jeweils nie bei irgendetwas zu fanatisch
und da beim Kajakfahren am Anfang
eigentlich gar nicht so mehr mein Papa
zu lieben gemacht weil der halt manchmal
im Sommer wiedergeben wollt was er
früher in der Studienzeit aufgemacht hat
und die war am Anfang recht ängstlich
beim Baden aber an zwar schlechte
Erfahrungen gemacht wie unter Wasser
immer so ein Boot rauskommen bin und so
und irgendwann hat dann aber der Papa
hat ein bisschen mit anderen Kinder und
Jugendlicher lustig finden und probieren
will dann habe ich das gemacht dann hat
sie Spaß gemacht und dann bin ich zu
meinem ersten Trainer im Kommen und der
hatte gefragt ob ihm besser in der
mittrainieren will weil es Schau ganz
talentiert aus dann oder wir haben Frau
trainieren kann und er gefragt ja kannst
du mir trainieren aber willst du
Weltmeister werden und die war da halt
zehn elf Jahre alt und so ich habe auch
eine für sich wenn es kommt dann nimmst
du auf die Art ja und so ist losgegangen
am nächsten Tag nach der Schule hat er
mir abgeholt und von da an ja ist es
halt Vollgas dahin gegangen was bedeutet
dir das Sport sehr sehr viel also schon
Sport habe wirklich viel lernen dürfen
sehr viel harte Erfahrungen machen
müssen aber auf die würde im Nachhinein
eine verzichten und extrem viel schöner
Erfahrungen machen können es ist für
mich ja etwas wo man wirklich für lernen
und mitnehmen kann wo man viele Leute
kennenlernt in beide Richtungen wieder
gut dass so wie Leute die weniger gut
sind und das ist für mich einfacher
universale Erfahrungen die man glaub
selten woanders im Leben so früh so auf
sondern einen großen Ebene schon machen
kann der lernt man sich natürlich auch
selbst sehr gut kennen das würdest Du
mir sagen ist deine stärkste Eigenschaft
ich glaube mein stärkster Eigenschaft
ist einfach mein Konsequenz das ähm wenn
ihr etwas mehr so vornehm oder so Plan
dass sie ist dann wirklich so 100%
verfolgt und ähm manchmal vielleicht
sogar bisschen weniger hat nicht dem
Nachsetzen sollte aber ich glaube das
ist ja etwas das ist mir dahin gebracht
hat wo ich bin ich habe gehört du hast
dich auch schon vorbereitet auf meine
nächste Frage
dein unnützes Talent was würdest du das
denn sagen das ist das vielleicht ist es
so dass Talente die nicht oft einsetzen
kann dass sie die dann recht schnell auf
die Seite stellen und das ist sie
irgendwann vergessen oder verlernen also
auf die Schnelle erfahrt man als
nächstes ein aber es gibt sicher einiges
was recht unnützes was sie kann aber
dann nicht weiter darum gekümmert das
heißt jetzt nicht der großartig
ausgebaut aber was wäre denn noch dein
großer Traum jetzt neben dem Olympia
ich glaube beim Sport merkt man dann
irgendwann recht schnell dass das sehr
wenn man so viel Zeit mit etwas
verbringt dass es sehr wichtig ist dass
es etwas ist was am Fall und das sage
ich gar nicht dass es unbedingt der
Sport für immer sein muss der Fall das
kann sie ja bei jedem persönlich ändern
waren auch immer wenn man hier früher
bei meiner später und wenn es dann
später oder früher einmal etwas anderes
sein sollte was man macht nach dem Sport
und das ist bei uns Sportarten meistens
so dass man dann auch noch was machen
muss dann sollte das vielleicht da etwas
sein was an ähnlich erfüllt in sport war
aber man Ehrgeiz und seine Ziele
entwickelt und das ist etwas was ich mir
wirklich wünscht dass sie später sowas
findet und nicht einfach nur die
restliche Arbeitszeit Durchschlag und
was was könnte es sein hast du schon
intensions ich versuche nebenbei im
Klaren Rahmen mein Informatik Studium
voran zu schreiben und mir wird auf
jeden Fall etwas in der Zukunft weißen
Richtung interessieren in welche genaue
Sprache von der Informatik oder es jetzt
gehen soll habe ich noch nicht
entschieden also bin ja noch nicht weit
genug aber ich würde auf jeden Fall
etwas eben wo man eben ja was Zukunft
orientiert ist was immer wieder neue
Ziele geben wird und neue
Challenges und das ist etwas glaube was
in der Sparte recht gut abgelegt haben
und das liegt auf jeden Fall gut jetzt
hast aber noch ein paar viele Jahre
Wildwasser vor der herzlichen Dank Felix
alles gute noch und viel Erfolg danke
dir das von uns vom Schwarzwald danke
dass Sie wieder mit dabei wart wir
freuen uns wenn ihr beim nächsten Mal
wieder da seid bis dann wiedersehen
[Applaus]